♪ [upbeat music plays]
Steve Jacobs: IDEAL Group is the umbrella,
or parent company,
to five subsidiary companies.
One is Apps4Android,
a developer of Android
accessibility applications.
Paul Speese: So at the show here,
we're demonstrating an application
that runs on an Android phone
or tablet, or television.
And the application consists of a number
of Bluetooth vital sign devices
that we've integrated and they
communicate to the phone.
So, the phone acts as a concentrator
and it collects all the data
and we convert that to medically
specific data formats,
encrypt it, send it up over the cloud, and
put it into an electronic medical record.
Steve Jacobs: Oh, when you say
"Android, I have a good feeling in my heart.
The reason I do is the Google,
the Android culture of Open Source.
It's built into the DNA.
People share code.
And it makes it so much easier
if I develop something
and somebody else can improve upon it
and I give them the code.
It gives them the leverage
to make the product better
without adding a lot of cost.
Paul Speese: The reason we're here today
in the Google Accessibility pod,
is with Apps4Android,
we've been able to take their expertise
in making applications accessible
for the blind
and low-cost, mobile health solutions
that help monitor people and alert medical
professionals to conditions that change
will really help to bring down cost
and provide a higher level of care.
Steve Jacobs: You talk to the community
you're developing applications for.
They won't hesitate to tell you
what they like,
what they don't like,
what they can and can't do.
And then if you hear the same thing
from enough people,
you know there's a market out there,
especially for Open Source applications.
00:01:52.208,00:00:00.000